okay move out
from out of the skies over Vietnam come
the screaming eagle the heroic
paratroopers of the 101st Airborne
Division their fatal exploits during
World War two can never be forgotten in
December 1944 outnumbered and surrounded
by the Germans at Bastogne the men of
the 101st courageously fought on when
the Germans ordered them to surrender or
be annihilated their acting commander
Brigadier General Anthony McAuliffe gave
the historic reply nuts and they stood
until the Germans were defeated it is in
this same tradition that the men of the
Screaming Eagles 1st Brigade today serve
on the jungle battlefront of Vietnam
on a warm spring day in 1965 several
army aviation companies arrived in
Vietnam aboard the carrier USS Iwo Jima
it is the beginning of the Army's Air
Mobility build-up the first of the
assault helicopters which soon will fill
the air over this embattled land even as
the pilots of the 101st Aviation
Battalion whirl away toward the field at
bomb Tao all of South Vietnam is
infested with Viet Cong from the north
they stream down the Ho Chi Minh Trail
and like a disease spread throughout the
southern Republic
into this setting come the first of the
Screaming Eagles the aviation proves of
company a forerunners in the massive
American military build-up to stop the
Communist enemy for the Republic this is
a time of desperation
here at Vung Tau airfield 40 miles
southeast of Saigon the job begins for
these Airmen along with helicopter crews
from other aviation companies the men of
the 101st are to be processed for move
them to their new homes in the forward
areas of Vietnam
their mission now is to create the
helicopter bases from which US Army
forces can be flown into combat against
the Vietcong quickly now they make ready
in the next 90 days before the airborne
infantry arrives these men will do a
man-sized job on the 29th of July 1965
the 1st Brigade of the 101st Airborne
Division arrives that camera on Bay
the brigade with its supporting elements
is commanded by Colonel James Timothy
who is welcome to Vietnam by ambassador
Maxwell Taylor
and by general william Westmoreland in
the ceremonies which follow Colonel
Timothy gets his first look at the
strife-torn shores of Vietnam and for
the first time the brigade unfurls the
proud emblem of freedom over the land it
is here to protect
to ambassador Taylor the occasion holds
a special meaning as the one time
commander of the 101st talks to his son
Captain Thomas Taylor now a member of
the Screaming Eagles concluding the
day's events some of the airborne
infantryman staged a parachute jump for
ambassador Taylor and general
Westmoreland it is to be one of the few
jumps these paratroopers will make in
Vietnam the screening Eagles descend
toward the earth and the unknown
hardships of jungle warfare they will
face in the months ahead
within two weeks after their arrival at
Cameron Bay the Screaming Eagles are
sent northward on their first combat
operation as they sail for keen yon 130
miles up the coast it is mid ox and the
brigade hasn't yet had time to establish
its permanent home base in Vietnam
you
while the Vietnamese are celebrating the
lantern festival the men of the 327th
and 502nd are moving inland from
Qingyuan to an cave in the central
highland their mission is to clear and
secure the on key area as a base camp
for the u.s. 1st Cavalry Division
airmobile which will be arriving from
the United States in a matter of days
at the among pass overlooking RK the
landings begin after months and special
training at Fort Campbell Kentucky this
is it the moment every man knew would
come a Viet Cong main force battalion
has been reported in the area and the
airborne infantryman expect instant
contact
but it doesn't come the vietcong are
evasive fighting their time it is an
anti-climax for the men this is their
first lesson in Vietnam no big battles
when expected instead a nagging war of
attrition with primitive booby traps and
snipers small unit actions and ambushes
in the jungle only when he thinks the
situation is favorable will the enemy
show himself in court
so the long hard task of ferreting out
the Communist enemy begins and the
Screaming Eagles are good at their job
by the end of September they will kill
600 Vietcong it will be a difficult
thing and some of these airborne
fighting men will die but the job for
this time will be done
as the advance elements of the 1st
Cavalry Division begin arriving at ante
they commence taking over the area
secured by the Screaming Eagles finally
the men of the 101st airborne are free
to head south and establish their own
home base in Vietnam the bank' and the
central highlands the brigade moves 170
miles to the coastal town of fan rang
this is to be their permanent camp as
soon as it can be to the Willie from
their campaign in the hill country they
worked throughout October until the base
at fan rang has been set up
general Westmoreland visits the
Screaming Eagles on Thanksgiving Day
1965 and inspects the camp at fan rank
he is pleased with their performance at
anche and congratulates them on a job
well done
even as he returns to Saigon the brigade
is conducting local search and clear
operation
as the new year begins the entire
brigade is deployed to 2 o'clock 100
miles to the north in Quyen province
known as the rice bowl this is the
richest rice growing region in central
Vietnam from this fertile area come
crops to feed all the people who central
Vietnam
but the Vietcong have been seizing the
harvest and collecting unbearable taxes
from the frightened farmers now come the
Screaming Eagles to protect the rice
hunt and stop the Vietcong codename
operation van Buuren the orders read
search out the enemy in the tuile art
sector and destroyer
this assignment will be tedious the VC
desert their dwellings and avoid
confrontation with the Americans yet the
district is infested with an enemy who
makes night raids and continues to
molest the farmers the search goes on
Brigadier General Willard Grissom takes
over command of the Screaming Eagles on
the 29th of January 1966 he steps up the
pressure on the Vietcong
across the broad reaches of Phu Yen
province the Vietcong are pursuing for
the most part they evade capture and
withdraw to disappear in hidden
underground sanctuaries in the wake of
US military operations the enemy rice
rage diminished but the VC themselves
mingle with the local people and often
are bypassed attacking our units from
the rear at night on 8 february the
deputy commander of the US military
assistance command vietnam Lieutenant
General John Hanke comes to to avoir to
personally evaluate the situation what
he sees convinces him that the enemy is
well entrenched in the district that it
will require repeated efforts by the
101st to dislodge these communist
guerrillas
operation Van Buren becomes operation
Harrison February becomes March and they
leave the Screaming Eagles patrol the
jungles and foothills surrounding the
rice fields of two aguar enemy main
force headquarters are located and hit
by the US Air Force with b-52 bombing
raids the men of the brigade go in to
check the results and prepare field
reports for Air Force intelligence
they leave they go out and daily they
return in 90 days the men of the brigade
gained control of the toy of our region
now operating in small units they kill
516 hardcore Vietcong troops between
February and April the rice crops are
saved
once early and much the men of the
brigade receive a surprise visit from
one of Hollywood's movie heroes Robert
Mitchum during this enjoyable interlude
there is talk about the glamorous girls
of the film world
mr. Mitchum has given the opportunity to
fire some of the weapons of the
real-life heroes in Vietnam
in mid-april 1966 the second battalion
of the 327th is left to guard the rice
harvest at wigwam and the rest of the
brigade moves out on operation austin
two weeks in the area around fam ket
then onward to non-code near the
Cambodian border here where the Ho Chi
Minh Trail enters South Vietnam the
Screaming Eagles meet the 141st Regiment
of the North Vietnamese Army for a while
the fighting is intense
the 502nd Airborne Infantry takes a
number of casualties it takes six days
from the 14th to the 20th of May for the
u.s. paratroopers to drive the North
Vietnamese aggressors out of their
positions in the foothills of Nong Cao
the communist regulars are well
disciplined well-equipped Antony in
spite of heavy ground fire Army aviators
get in with their dust off helicopters
and the wounded are whisked away to
safety
this is the enemy when he was captured
he was carrying a machine gun made in
Czechoslovakia he won't be using it
again
as for his comrades they have been put
to rock and in their hasty flight they
have dropped their arms over 100 of the
North Vietnamese live dead in the
mountains victory at non-coal his hours
but for the Screaming Eagles the
greatest testing is still to come far to
the north in come to improvin s-- the
brigade launches Operation Hawthorn in
the area around docto come to him is a
forbidding wilderness lying in the
foothills of the mountain country which
marks the border of Cambodia it is the
first week of June and the air is heavy
and
under now the enemy has held sway here
thirty miles north of the little town of
Dokdo the airborne engineers erect the
crude bridge a few miles beyond lies an
American Special Forces camp it has been
under siege by the Vietcong for nearly a
week supplies and ammunition are badly
needed and relief troops must get
through the first of the trucks
begins crossing near the bridge the men
of B battery 320th artillery prepare for
another firing mission throughout the
morning they have rained harlots or
shells upon the enemy forces attacking
the camp now with fresh supplies of
ammunition they're ready to begin again
each time the shelling starts the enemy
withdraws his attacking forces to escape
the punishing fires when it is lifted he
regroups and again tries to take the
camp despite week-long airstrikes by US
Air Force jets the Vietcong have shown
no signs of withdrawing but the
artillery fire directed by those
defending the outpost is having a
telling effect
the Screaming Eagles are under fire the
enemy has come to silence the guns
communists fire comes from everywhere
out there the enemy is creeping in he
will try to overrun the American
positions the waiting is agony
them the enemy makes his move this is it
live or die
in the forefront general Pearson the
boss here inhale from Bastogne to the
earth Nam the tradition remains unbroken
Magnus the screaming
the battle waves a small part of
Operation Hawthorn is over some of the
men of the 101st will fight no more but
for this day the bastions of freedom
held they came from the north of both
Italian their weapons not ours have been
silenced throughout the oppressive days
and nights of June 1966 operation
Hawthorn continues in the violent
conflict which rages in come to in
Provence the Screaming Eagles repeatedly
beat back prized troop units of the
North Vietnamese Army
in 16 straight days of combat the
brigade envelops the 24th north
vietnamese army regiment and more than
500 of the Communist aggressors are
killed it is the largest single battle
of the war for the men of the 101st
the feather struggled to preserve the
freedom of this little Asian nation is
made more bearable as each man is
enriched in spirit and strengthened in
his resolve
at last the fighting is done
all the world had heard about the
gallant Screaming Eagles and the battles
of operation hopper in recognition of
their outstanding victory in kuntum
province the premier of south vietnam
luan Kalki comes to the little town of
dr. premier key in the deputy premier
expressed the gratitude of their nation
in a way that fighting men can
understand
these are some of the weapons taken from
the enemy the premier is told in the
hands of the Communists the arms of
china poland czechoslovakia russia and
even a variety of the united states
french and british weapons which had
fallen into those same enemy han
living evidence of the North Vietnamese
Regular Army six out of the 22 taken
alive by the screening Eagle premier key
confronts the aggressors you are lucky
the Americans have taken you he smiled
on the 21st of July
following surveillance operations along
the ocean and Cambodian borders the
brigade returns to to acquire a new
operation labeled John Paul Jones gets
underway its purpose is to open and
secure a 16 mile stretch of national
highway one between two avoir and von
Raab a on the coast the accomplishment
of this mission will speed up logistic
support of the to leave our area by
permitting ships to unload at the nearby
Bay it begins with elements of the 502nd
infantry landing at the cliff guarded
von Raab a where without encountering
resistance they begin moving inland to
link up with the oncoming units of the
327
the inland forces push forward securing
the highway and sweeping the adjoining
countryside
supported by helicopter gunships
heliborne assault troops clean up the
operational zone within six weeks by
early September 1966 they have secured
bomber obey and highway 1 North totally
far
sweeping through the mountains the
brigade captures 14 North Vietnamese and
Vietcong and kills 209
while operation John Paul Jones is still
in progress
the engineers begin construction work on
the connecting highway between vorobei
and highway 1 the screening Eagles have
done their job well and a new seaport is
born
in the weeks which follow the brigade
protects the rice farmers as they
harvest some 17,000 metric tons of the
precious grain once again the to leave
our sector becomes the battlefield and
the Vietcong suffer heavy losses with
239 killed and 42 captured
the Vietcong have had enough they are
nowhere to be found
eleven Vietnamese are found however in a
Vietcong prison camp they have
apparently received no medical attention
while in the hands of the Communist held
by the Vietcong for several months their
ailments range from open sores and skin
infections from malnutrition
as well as deformity is caused by unset
broken ball
this man a former Vietcong who defected
to the Republic and was later captured
by the VC cannot tell of his unspeakable
nightmare with the enemy
on the 9th of December the Odyssey of
the brigade continues from Torrey Park
back up north to come to him province
the Vietcong have been cleared from
Fujian province by this time and the
Screaming Eagles are moved to the north
in a record 48 hours by the US air force
the deployment of the brigade by means
of parachute march the first jump in
more than a year for many of the men but
they're in superb physical conditions
and the chapel goes well
as 1966 draws to a close the brigade
descends upon come to muffins to take
part in operation picket fighting side
by side with vietnamese army forces and
militia the men of the 101st once again
will scour the countryside finding and
finishing the enemy
the operations and contemn province
continue until the 21st of January 1967
then after more than a year's absence
from their home base at Phan rang the
brigade is ordered back for arrest it
seems a long time since the LSTs first
moved the brigade of the qing young as
they headed for their first combat
around on k now
the LSTs are taking them home
on the 26 the last convoy rolls into
camp at van rang Brigadier General
Willard kissing welcomes the men home it
will be one of his last official act as
brigade commander
two days later general Pearson transfers
command of the 1st Brigade 101st
Airborne Division to the new brigade
commander Brigadier General SH Madison
the battle-hardened troops watched with
solemn pride as Lieutenant General
Engler pins the Legion of Merit on the
uniform of their departing commander so
the Screaming Eagles bid farewell to the
commander who led them in 14 combat
operations from one end of the at Nam to
the other for the Screaming Eagles as
for the rest of the United States
military forces in Vietnam the valiant
effort to keep that young nation free
continues however far removed from our
shores the conflict between those who
cherish human dignity and those who
would snuff it up affects us all
in this belief the gallant men of the
United States Army stand steadfast not
only in Southeast Asia but wherever they
may be asked to serve in freedom's car
you